30 miles north of Petra I'm laser
scanning the ancient city of Sela
for the very first time I'm looking for
clues that the nomadic neva teens
settled here
look at this whose pottery just like
falling out of the ground that's the
indication for people living here this
is somebody's finger pressed exactly my
finger fits perfectly so something
that's crazy
please feel somebody's fingerprint right
here locked in time the pottery proves
people were here but it's not clear who
it could simply be the guards charged
with protecting the Nabataeans treasure
a staircase where does it go
[Music]
[Music]
probably it's a place to pray yes
solutely you think so yeah you look for
a high place to be closer to the regards
[Music]
so far all I've found is a piece of
pottery in an ancient stairway to heaven
I guess this is all sandstone right yes
it is so over 2,000 years the landscape
is sort of melted away
the desert winds and winter rains are
eroding the soft sandstone into strange
shapes
[Music]
but I can just make out curious regular
markings in the rocks
[Music]
where these little holes appear so
actually this is the traditional
Nabataean house so they were living here
and you can see the marks of the axe
that we have been using to carving as
this house chisel marks yes exactly
wait you're sitting here chiseling away
creating a space for their family name
Carbon caves into dwellings suggests
that they spent long stretches of time
here look at the beautiful view here
it's unbelievable this is the East the
Sun will come up it will be sunny in
this spot the caves position reveals the
reason for the strange regular markings
above the entrance their post holes for
their tent poles you'll have this you
know shelter in front of your house so
they've gone from living in tents to
combining tents with living in stone
then
[Music]
the evidence is stacking up that homes
were created at Sela
but it's hot exposed and desert dry
without a single water source on the
whole outcrop
no one can survive without water so how
did the Nabataeans I'm hoping my lidar
data can help solve the mystery
[Music]